also if you're in the uk or america or
any other country please like our video
and subscribe if you're on youtube any
interaction
on audio please rate us it helps a lot
thank you very much here today tiffany
jessica gina and nikki
and we are talking about habits
because i know look me in the eyeballs
i know you [ __ ] got some bad habits
you want to break
this one okay
okay let's talk about it and then also
some good habits that maybe you want to
bring into your life the [ __ ] new
year's coming wow
the new year the new year is coming the
new year
and also if you have to adjust for the
pandemic um
maybe it's been hard for you because you
haven't created the new habits that
could
accommodate that lifestyle at home so
you feel like a bum all the time
we i will um i'm basing most of this off
of a book that i just read that a lot of
people have been reading right now and i
think it's a really really
good book it's called atomic habits by
james clear
he i wish i had all of his credits in
front of me right now but i don't sorry
james
but from what i remember he actually was
a baseball player
and he got he had a huge injury but then
made his way back into playing college
ball he never went beyond college ball
but
they didn't even think he was going to
be able to play college ball and it was
a big feat for him
then he decided to figure out what what
about him made him
be able to play again and not other
people that get injured and that's when
he discovered
habits and how he was able to
incorporate them into his lifestyle and
become
one percent better uh increment by
increment and it compounded over time to
make him
you know superior as an athlete as
opposed to people that maybe don't
incorporate those habits and
since then he gets hired by fortune 500
companies to train
their whole staff and like a lot of what
he does is
just focus on the minutia that
maybe people overlook that make all the
big difference in the world in the long
run
well what now the minutia y'all just
making a words at this point
you've never heard of that word no it's
a common word even i know gina
like if tim knows the word his nose you
see i have
never heard this word what does this
mean it's like this is my minor thing
oh a minute oh yeah yeah a plural of
that
okay so i'm just gonna touch on some of
the concepts that he brought up in the
book and we could talk about
maybe how they've applied to our own
lives and stuff
i'm not going to go over everything it's
a pretty uh hefty book but i
highly recommend reading it because he
cites a lot of focus group studies and
scientific information how brains work
and all kinds of good
[ __ ] if you want to know exactly why
these things work
um but basically the act of repeating
habits with one percent error or one
percent gains
small choices every day can create very
big results and he calls this the
the compounding what is it like uh what
does he say he calls this the compound
interest of self-improvement
when you just focus on getting a little
bit better each time
and he brought up this example that i
thought was so so
cool um about how the uk had this
well actually uh england in particular
had this bicycle team and they tried to
compete in like the tour de france every
year
but they could never make it and they
were so bad like so
famously bad that these like good
bike companies like people that made
bikes wouldn't even let them
ride their bikes or didn't want to be
associated with like an exciting
brand name because you you saw them
they bought it for themselves we're not
gonna sponsor yeah
and you can't even don't pick up the
brand names don't even show them i wish
you can do that with the ex-boyfriend
she'd be like now that we broke up don't
even
yeah don't like you blame me all the
cool things i taught you
unlearn it you need to end you have to
be lame nda yeah you need to register
the
ip for that this never happened
yeah and so anyway so they were so
[ __ ] bad and
um like until 2003 no british cycler had
ever won the tour de france
so then they hired this new performance
director who focused on making these one
percent improvements so they did little
things like
they redesigned the bike seats for more
comfort they rubbed
alcohol on the tires for a better grip
they had bikers wear like heated over
shorts to maintain the ideal muscle
temperature you did it over
short yeah because it's cold it's like
battery powered or something
i don't know how the heated shorts maybe
they're objects i'm sorry
he actually died very deep there's a
whole chapter on these shorts
all i'm picturing is a man and his penis
inside some heated shorts
and if his balls are very comfortable
they are very cozy i want to know how
they
they're not the shirt that is what they
call my vagina the heated shorts and
that's what they put their wiener in
heated penis mitt yeah there you go i am
the penis mitt
yeah so they like tested all kinds of
fabrics including the heated ones
they tested massage gels for what has
the fastest muscle recovery
they had a surgeon teach everyone how to
wash their hands most efficiently to not
catch a cold
yeah everything they determined what
type of pillow and mattress led to the
best sleep
even painted the inside of the truck
like the team truck white
so they could spot bits of dust that
would normally be overlooked that might
have like
interfered with the finely tuned bikes
so down to the
tiniest minutiae gina he was like
focused on the word
hyper focused on all these little things
and they got
just a little beetsy beansy bit better
every single time that could mean the
world
and within exactly within five years
they crushed the 2008 olympics
won 60 of the gold medals and cyclings
four years later they sent nine olympic
gold records and seven
world records and uh bradley wiggins
became the first brit to
enter the tour to win the tour de france
and then the next year his teammate
also the british cyclist on that team
chris froome
won and then he won again the next three
consecutive years
so during the 10-year span from 2007 to
2017
british cyclists won 178 world
championships
66 olympic or paralympic gold medals and
five tour de france victories
whereas before then they won jack [ __ ]
they couldn't even place
i think i might have missed this but so
what's sparked this
change or they suck so bad but like who
they hired somebody
oh yeah they hired a performance
especially so how does this book author
know about that he just he just studied
them okay yeah so that's how he
came up or he got inspired too well this
is just one of the
examples to kind of highlight the whole
overall theme of like how
focusing on details one percent better
every day
can you get your compounded interest of
self-improvement
yeah and it's just the things that
normally people would overlook or they
think is not a big deal
and you don't really see the results
right away you know you're like you eat
a cookie you don't gain 10 pounds the
next day
but you eat a cookie every hour
for every day and then you start to see
these compounded results so
whether it's going one percent in the
negative direction or the positive
it shapes who you become as a person
over time without you really realizing
it this is like a video games because
there's stuff that you can like like you
can hp
reload speed by like 0.01 and you don't
think about it as much but if you keep
on
leveling it up and adding to that you
eventually it compounds to a bit
exactly you have an advantage over your
enemy i think this is something that
athletes just know like
athletes that are really good they they
already know this maybe not consciously
like
or in the front of their mind they know
this but like that's i feel like this is
what every athlete
that i've ever known they're just like
i'm like really do i really
have to skip you know the extra calories
today does it really matter they're like
if you want to reach your goal it the
little the
the one cookie doesn't matter the one
thing like it does
matter and like you know that and it
dies between good to great
right we can all be good and just kind
of forget about the details
but you'll never be great though so like
they're just teaching you not to be
discouraged just because you're doing a
small thing at a time
exactly you don't see results it adds up
over time
gratification yeah actual change or like
it's like people who go to the gym and
they expect to do like 500
reps of everything at first and then
once they don't see the results they're
like oh
whatever or you're like they say you're
supposed to start small yeah
if you don't see anything just so that's
the reason most people stop doing the
good habits because they don't see the
progress right away and so it
um it really makes a huge like
difference
i don't know i i'm really bad at doing
them every day
yeah that's where i i just haven't found
something that
can have me keep me accountable to do
the
the one good thing that i'm like the
habit that i'm trying to build even if
it's really small
every day i can't say like i'll skip
days and i'm like oh [ __ ] i was supposed
to do that thing
so that's what this book is about so
teach me it's so good okay that means i
have to read this book every day too
till i finish it
also i'll give you these books too i
don't even do them every day
i'll like i'll binge like [ __ ] 10
chapters one day
and then i'll go like two months without
opening the book again and then the next
like third month then i actually
finished a book or something but that
even that yeah
it can't even be consistent it's on a
daily thing
yeah and that's kind of like the same
concept as like when
it was crash dieting you know where like
you might see
results faster but then you go back to
your old ways events
eventually because you weren't focused
on the system of getting there you were
focused on the results and seeing it
right away and that's
the first thing he brings up is that
like forget about
goals like too many people are focused
on goals like i want to save a million
dollars or
like i want to you know hit this
benchmark and he says to instead focus
on systems because
if you think about it both winners and
losers have the same goals
maybe laugh out loud when i read that i
was like that's true
so achieving a goal um basically only
changes
things for a moment whereas creating
these systems
changes who you are as a person your
like internal
identity and therefore like even if you
slip up you still come back to
this version of you that you like um and
goals restrict your happiness because
you think
that a lot of people think that you can
only be happy when you achieve that
certain thing and so when you
fall in love oh and listen when you
don't achieve that thing you like you
can't be happy or it's like this thing
that you're always chasing
um but when you fall in love with the
process instead of the product
you don't have to like wait to give
yourself permission to be happy
i love that yeah i like that too because
i think that
um i do some i used to get really
wrapped up
in that goal and determined like my
metrics of success were based around
whether i hid it or not and more often
than not i didn't hit it
and so i would slip into like
self-sabotaging behavior because i'm
like well if i didn't get it then
i might as well not do anything you know
that reminds me of a
really really weird thing that i do to
myself and i
i don't even know how it correlates to
what you just said but somehow in my
brain it linked it
but sometimes um like i will
i'll be in the middle of a test let's
say let's say i am
washing the dishes and i'm washing the
dishes but i have to pee
so [ __ ] bad yeah and i'm like no you
can't go pee until you're done washing
these [ __ ] dishes and i'll hold it in
and then finally when i'm done washing
the dishes i'm like running to the
bathroom because i'm about to pee my
pants
but like what the [ __ ] is that you could
how do i do that you created
um some sort of negative cue for
yourself that like
people who go to the thing that they
need to do
instead of finishing the task are not
good people or like you you created some
sort of subconscious
meaning behind it that like you're
you're not allowed to have
it's actually you created a reward
system that's what it is that's what i
do
the how to create good habits you give
yourself a reward that like
it's part of human nature but your
biology like you need to pee
yeah but especially if you don't trust
yourself to finish because you think if
if you stop then you won't finish it oh
maybe since every time you stop
something you wait
two months maybe you need to train
yourself oh my god that's what it is
you [ __ ] nailed it nailed it we need
a reward system is what we need
go pee beforehand and give yourself a
different reward
that's true i need like an intense
reward system like that i remember i
been with my friend like 500 bucks i'm
like don't give this back to me until i
clean my room
oh that's great that's perfect you were
doing actually one of the
one of the systems without even knowing
it that's kind of what i liked about
this book is because i was doing a lot
of these things but i didn't know why
certain habits stuck in certain ones
didn't
right um and then this kind of really
clarified like oh
because i did that that's why that one's
stuck yeah
i'm gonna get a goal maybe i should do
that i should just like venmo you five
thousand dollars and i'm gonna have to
send you a video of myself working out
every day
and if i don't send you a video then i'm
not gonna get my money back
yeah that's better that's a lot of money
yeah every day i won't [ __ ]
do it like that's why like i had a
trainer before i paid a trainer that's
the only way i would get myself to work
out now that the gyms are not open
i don't have a trainer i'm not working
out and my body is falling apart
but i still won't [ __ ] i don't want
to work out in my apartment it's boring
yeah it's hard yeah you should do
whatever then it works
because i am very very motivated by many
people
dude i've done this multiple times like
five hundred dollars for me to clean my
room
and i think we did like another like
another 500 if i lose 15 pounds
like like it works because it's like
yeah i don't want to lose my money i
want my
money because it's 500 i might be like
[ __ ] it but if i send her five thousand
dollars i'd be like i need to get that
money back
worse i get five thousand dollars of
your own money
no no way more money yeah
um yeah and something came to me during
while you were saying that
oh that you should be part of this too
because i was thinking the same thing
send me the money
yes divide it up between yeah
you're like so you don't think i'm going
to work out i mean you don't know how
i'm motivating on it
yeah we just want them maybe we might
get you you don't know how motivated my
money i am i used to have that
when you're starting out with youtube um
because it's still weird like
industry and like when you first start
working for yourself you don't know
like you're like oh i'm not getting a
paycheck i'm not clocking in and out i
had to
pay myself a salary like if i got paid a
big chunk of money from a different job
i would put in the bank and then only
pay myself 200 a week if i completed x
amount of videos
so it was like i was collecting a
paycheck i had to clock into work i
would never do that
so you had two bank accounts or how did
you move the money yeah i had two bank
accounts yeah i had a saving i mean i
still had the money but
i wasn't allowed to spend it or touch it
or do anything with that money
unless i finished my work it did work
yeah um but yeah anyway uh so
he also says that um that
goals are at odds with long-term
progress because like say you're a
runner and you train
for months but as soon as you cross the
finish line you stop training
like all the hard work is focused on
that particular goal so once you
hit it you stop trying are you like
that's what happened with me with weight
lifting
i was so dead that was like the the six
months of my life
in my entire life that i was so proud of
myself
because i didn't even recognize that i
didn't recognize myself so i had
bart as my trainer and he was the one
that was kind of i didn't want to put
like i didn't want to let him down
because he put the time into creating
the training schedule for me so i was
just like i'm not going to let that work
go to waste
and so for those six months religiously
three times a week
i was working out and i would see those
tiny little increments of weight
like i was able i was getting stronger
and stronger and then finally when i hit
my goal
which was to i squatted
a plate which was 45 pounds each so it's
45 times three
numbers now is that 135 140 130. i don't
remember
this one 30 44 or 45 times
three whatever number that is i squatted
that and i deadlifted that and then i
benched 95 and i was just like those are
my goals
and i hit you [ __ ] [ __ ]
i know so then you hit them and you stop
doing any of it tiny arms
and you benched 95. was it 95 now i'm
getting confused
now you're making me doubt myself was it
that's a lot for a girl
i don't remember i feel like it was i
think it could be yeah i think it was
if you're squatting 140 135
yeah i think that's the first thing you
remember it's usually the right answer
probably
okay yeah cause i just remember it was
40s depressed i'm impressed yeah
i'm sure 95 for this yes i remember and
then so i hit it well 45 times the 45 is
like he's telling you what plate to put
on right but the weight is 135 because
it's a bar
plus two plus for some reason i can't
remember the easy number which is the
whole number
yeah yeah i just remember because i know
the bar weighs 45
each plate is 45 that's 45 times three
anyway the point is i finally hit the
goal
and then the first day going back to the
gym after like
a vacation i ended up hitting like i
[ __ ] up my shin and i was like that's
it
for me yeah the box jumps and i never
went back to weightlifting ever again
yeah yeah i hit my goal and i'm like
[ __ ] this yeah cause you weren't in love
with the process you were
loving my body afterwards dude seriously
lifting weight every girl should lift
weights
yeah like literally every girl it
changes your body so much another thing
is
in a good way especially her day and i
threw up and i stopped oh my gosh she
went too hard
you needed to go to one percent
seriously you would never even have to
get any sort of work done on your body
your body would just be
sick yeah i know that was my favorite
body ever and then on top of that
uh and it's natural for women our bones
like deterioration
yeah a lot faster than men's and lifting
weights actually
slows the process yeah it doesn't
prevent it but it slows the process
it doesn't die yeah so
how do you build a good system how do
you fall in love with that process well
i'll talk about it
after we talk about our boobs yes first
you're gonna fall in love with third
love
so third love is an amazing
bra company so i actually owned two of
their bras and i'm currently wearing
one there you see the straps there we go
there's just a slight
sneak peek a little tease a little tiny
little piece [ __ ]
third love you call me so third love
uses the measurements of millions of
women to design bras
with all day comfort and support so
what you first do is you go on their
website you take the fit finder quiz
which will find the size and styles are
right for you
in 60 seconds it will help you identify
your breast size and shape and fi
find the styles that really just work
the best for your particular body
and they have the perfect fit promise so
if you don't love it
every customer has 60 days to return and
returns and exchanges are free and easy
and third love donates all of their
gently used return bras to women in need
supporting charities in their local san
francisco bay area
and across the united states so they
have these signature details like
memory foam cups no slip straps and
scratch free
band and third love creates better bras
that focus on what
matters keeping you comfortable no
shortcuts no
substitutions third love knows there's a
perfect bra for everyone so right now
they are offering
our listeners 10 off your first order go
to thirdlove.com
big mood now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 10
off your first purchase that's
thirdlove.com
big mood for 10 off today yay
yay and when you got a good bra going on
you want good clothes to put over that
so
if you need some help with your personal
styling you can
order some stitch fix stitch fix is like
a having a stylist
that's picking out clothes just for you
at a fraction of the cost of an actual
stylist
um so citrix offers clothing um by going
onto their site you can fill out a
personality quiz it's not really a
personality quiz they show you
pictures and then you pick the one that
you like you ex the ones that you don't
like and from that selection
yeah style quiz and then from that
selection they can
put together what your personal style is
and
curate a wardrobe for you citrix offers
different and fun clothing that you'll
love to wear every piece is chosen for
your fit in your life and it's the easy
solution
to finding what makes you look good and
feel your best you can try out pieces at
home before you buy you keep what you
love return what you don't
stitchfix has free shipping easy returns
and exchanges and a prepaid return
envelope is included so you don't gotta
think about it and there's no
subscription required you don't gotta
subscribe to anything
just try search fix once or set up
automatic deliveries you pay just a 20
styling fee for each box which gets
credited towards the pieces that you
keep
and there are no there are no hidden
fees ever they have styles and clothing
to fit any occasion for
women men and kids they ship all over
the us and available in the uk as well
mate get started today at stitchfix.com
mood and you'll get 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.com and you'll get 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
stitchfix.com
mood where were we how do we
build good systems yeah how do we do it
because everyone's like there's always
like okay [ __ ] i guess there's always
like things to do people are always
telling me you gotta do this but i'm
like
but i still don't do it yeah that's my
problem how do i
just do it because you know what else is
very interesting about me and you jess
is that we are able to create systems in
our homes
like we're [ __ ] organized [ __ ] but
how do we do this in
habit world okay so how you do it
is by focusing on identity based habits
rather than
outcome based habits so instead of
focusing on what you want to achieve
focus on who you want to become and each
habit
is a vote for your new identity so when
you are
in your home dress and you're like that
should work out but i don't really want
to
when you choose to work out you're
voting like i'm the type of person that
works out
you're voting for that identity and it's
just
you know one vote here and there will
make a difference so many other things
that
have ch changed and molded my identity
from a year or two i know
i love it i guess that makes sense like
i am the
i want to be the type of person that
wakes up works out has a [ __ ]
smoothie or something like i do want to
be that
yeah but then usually it's just like
easier to sit on the couch totally that
reminds
me of uh it totally is so when you make
that vote you're voting to be
a gina which is setting the intention
she's like do you want to be a gina
that's kind of happy i am
[Laughter]
to change no but yeah that reminds me of
like setting the intentions
like um because so that book title it's
kind of close to the other book that i
keep talking about called breaking the
habit of being yourself because the word
habits in there yeah but
in that book it talks about how if you
set your intentions
to your like atomic level pretty much
like you like truly one thousand and ten
percent that you are
that person that let's say works out
every single day
like i am that person that works out
every day like there's no doubt about it
like i literally feel like i am
and i am and then by just having that
mentality
slowly like automatically the actions
like they
they do themselves you subconsciously
want to uphold that identity
yeah you've told yourself it over and
over like we become the stories that we
tell ourselves
so if it's like i'm a person that works
out but then you don't work out it's
like going against your
yeah you are positive dissonance yeah
exactly
you into doing it yes maybe yeah and so
whenever you don't work out it's a vote
against
it's a vote for being a lazy piece of
[ __ ] so you're like
i guess enough votes that way you i'm
like
okay i guess i'm voting to be a lazy
piece of [ __ ] and the more you're aware
of
where you're voting then you can
consciously start shifting it
and you start to feel good when you make
the vote for the person that you want to
be and you become more in alignment with
that person
and it doesn't because i like the voting
analogy because it's like
you don't need a hundred percent of the
vote but the majority
of the vote yeah because i'm gonna say
when does it get
unhealthy to where you're like if i
didn't do the habit then now i hate
myself
right i mean i don't think you should
ever hate yourself in fact the first
time
people that's what they struggle with i
think though when building a habit
they're like they're scared of starting
something new because they're like oh if
i don't do it for a day or a weekend
then i'm gonna let myself down and i
just want to avoid
feeling like i let myself down entirely
so i just won't even bother starting the
new habit
yeah he actually talks about that first
and i guess i skimmed over it because
um i feel like a lot of what we talked
about in the beginning was mindset but
an activity or an exercise to do is
think about your
regular day like or maybe you could do
it while you're doing your day
write down what he calls a scorecard
just every habit that you do
write it down on a list and don't judge
your habits just write them down like as
an
outside observer so if i like pick my
butt yeah
every day i don't think that is that
true that happens regularly yeah if it's
every day then write it down i
i my butt cheeks often swallow my
underwear so every day i pick my butt is
that a habit
i mean i guess it could be a habit it
just sounds efficient to me to pick it
out
sounds like the logical thing to do
something comfortable if you leave
you're a logical person
so i mean how extensive is this list
what does it really look like is the
negative things that i do is
the fact that everything every i sat on
social media for four years try not to
label things as negative or positive
when you're doing this particular
exercise just go woke up at
7am uh went downstairs made a cup of
coffee
put creamer in it put x amount of
creamer in it um
wow that went upstairs detailed yeah
went upstairs how many steps did you
brush my teeth downstairs just kidding
it took 13 times
like i'm not a list no just once just
once
so then you can kind of look and really
take a good look at what you do every
day
these are the type of habits that you do
on a regular basis this is like a sample
size of it and then yeah my name does
not look the same every day wake up
yeah and so maybe for you you can do a
couple different days to take an
accurate sample
but put a check mark next to the habits
that you want to keep
and then put an x next to the ones that
you'd like to change but don't beat
yourself up
over one's like [ __ ] i shouldn't eat in
that chocolate bar or anything like that
just
be conscious of it and now you're aware
and so now you can start to make votes
that's actually it reminds me of when i
was doing the weightlifting i was also
tracking macros which is like fats
proteins and carbs
and before and so i had a macro coach
and
before we did anything before that coach
gave me any sort of numbers to follow he
was like okay
take a few days just write down
everything that you're eating like don't
try to
be healthier or go easier or whatever it
is yeah it's just like
don't see where you started yeah exactly
just see where you're starting
they uh the statistically people that
keep food journals when they're trying
to
achieve a weight goal or like lose
weight or just become
a more active person they see progress
faster than
people that don't keep a food journal
because it's easy if you're not
conscious of it to keep repeating bad
habits and those are
compounding over time as we talked about
earlier and so
if at least you're aware of them then
you can begin to shift and change them
but if you're not aware you don't know
what to change i had an issue with the
macros saying because it it starts to
turn into like
um i don't know i feel like being that
detailed like or having to keep a food
journal over a long period of time like
maybe if you really have
like zero self-awareness and you don't
realize why you're gaining weight
it's good for like maybe a few weeks but
i feel like that long-term
like list taking of the food creates
issues with food in people so that's
that's the only thing that i'm scared of
like saying oh write down everything you
eat because it could like
trigger like an eating disorder yeah
yeah and it's that i mean definitely
it's personal and if
you have a history of eating disorders
that's something you should see a
psychologist yeah well if you start to
have some of those mental behavior
because
i think after doing the work i was able
to do a few like i went through an
eating disorder
in high school in a bit of college um
and i
had to do a lot of work to reverse that
psychology and so and i know what my
triggers are and everything and i'm very
conscious about it
but so now over years of not having one
um i was able to keep a food journal the
last time i had sibo last year
and um be able to like at least analyze
food without making it a
a psychological thing yeah about my
image you know it was more about
um helping curing this health thing that
i had yeah
yeah um but you know if it's triggering
you obviously don't do it
or at least be aware that it could so
like if you do drink a soda and you
took in 30 grams of sugar like you know
like you'll get to a point when you're
counting macros i think a lot of people
don't realize that where they start to
get
too they beat themselves up over like oh
i just really wanted a soda but now i'm
[ __ ] 30 grams of sugar over my macros
and it's just like becomes a thing
macros don't work for me i it made me
more stressed out i feel like it's kind
of unhealthy but no one says it but
keeping a food journal
without like being like i need this
amount of protein or carbs or anything
just keeping a food journal and
observing what i was eating
it did help for me because then you're
like uh maybe i'm eating too many
cookies maybe i won't like when i go to
the store i just won't buy the cookies
this time
so that they're not so accessible yeah
versus like oh i ate a cookie today i'm
over my sugar macros now i [ __ ] i
failed
right you know i'm never gonna [ __ ]
get my goal like then you start hating
yourself
yeah don't ever get to the point of
hating yourself but it's i guess a
better enough or a different analogy
would be
with money we did in a money episode
where we're talking about budgeting
and having all of your dollars budgeted
out on paper before you ever spend them
is a great habit to get into then once
you kind of have it down
you know like what's coming in and
what's going on yeah you don't need to
write it down anymore
because it's kind of ingrained in you
and the same with the food journal like
after you got it like you kind of get
what you're eating
my plate should look like yeah i know
that the meat portion should look like
this the rice portion should probably be
smaller but look like this and then the
vegetables should look like this
exactly and you know if you skipped out
on your vegetables that day it's no
longer like
some people if they've never recorded it
they don't realize how they're missing
eating vegetables like they don't even
touch them all week
and then they're like oh [ __ ] i didn't
even know i wasn't eating vegetables
but after you've recorded it for so long
and you made those adjustments it just
comes
more second nature and you'll know so
that's the idea behind
tracking your habits yeah yeah exactly
um yeah so he says to focus on identity
based habits and uh each habit is a vote
for your new identity
and like for example the goal is not to
read a book
the ol the goal is to be a reader it's
not to run a marathon
but to be a runner so you're in love
with the process
not the actual so then i guess if if you
say oh i'm a reader but then
when you really think about it you're
like i don't really care for that to be
my identity like would you
should you then really try to force
yourself to read books or can you just
be like
i'm an audio listener i like listening
to podcasts yeah i like listening to
audiobooks i won't be a reader
but i'll be a listener i'll take my dog
in a walk and i'll listen to books like
i don't have to like buy books and force
myself to
yeah it's the identity that fits for you
yeah you know so a lot of people
that's a great thing that you brought up
because like for example a lot of people
think they want to be famous you know
right now a lot of kids want to be
famous but then
they don't realize what actually being
famous and
entails like someone holding a
microscope to your life every second of
your day
is not fun and so like maybe you think
you want to be
something and then you try it out and
you're like oh [ __ ] this actually isn't
for me like a lot of people think they
want to work for themselves
but then they realize like it's really
[ __ ] hard to set your own schedule
and not know where your next check is
coming from yeah yeah
then you have to like book your own gigs
and get your own work and keep up with
your clients and do things for
all your taxes and yeah yeah it's not
like a piece of cake
it sounds so ideal you're like i work
for myself
but then when you actually are that not
that fun maybe to you
a lot of times it's easier just to rely
on someone else you don't know people
don't realize it's just like oh you're
just a streamer i was just like
no i'm a streamer i do my own marketing
business accounting i do my own
everything
like yeah you know that's a compliment
turn it off that's a compliment to you
gina because you make it look effortless
yeah people don't know that there's
actually brain rattling around in there
somewhere in there and it's usually just
elevator music
really pretty elevator yeah yeah so he
says to like you know catch yourself
when you're telling yourself stories too
like
instead of saying like you might say to
yourself a lot i'm not a morning person
but you would really like to tip does
that i'm like i think you've convinced
yourself that you're not
yeah yeah that's true no but then yeah
like and then reading this book and i'm
like
i am a morning person i love waking up
in the morning
so then vote for that like every time
when you're doing your scorecard it's
like woke up at seven
check that lines up with me being a
morning person
that's too early what are some bad
habits that you guys have broken
oof tahin i lost track
i mean it was just very short-lived but
yeah eating ducking
out of my purse i used to be this i used
to be a professional
crackhead smoker yeah i'm so proud of
you that i didn't know
you know amazing yeah i never really saw
the thing that tracks how many days it's
been
yeah i don't really like to talk about
it that much but like
and but i i feel like i can't really
take credit for it because like
one day it just started getting like
really dizzy spells
um i started getting dizzy a lot and so
i i kind of
panicked i was like i don't want to
smoke because i'm now it's making me
dizzy like
not the dizzy where you're like oh this
is my first cigarette i'm kind of dizzy
but it was like literally i feel like
i'm gonna fall over and like maybe
am i having a stroke like something's
wrong like but maybe it was an inner ear
thing i don't know but like i just
started getting panic attacks
from the idea of smoking so that's what
stopped me it wasn't even like i did it
of my own volition
well i didn't give you some credit
because some people are so attached to
the identity of being a smoker that it
doesn't matter if it's [ __ ] up their
life or whatever well yeah so i never
cared like about my lungs hurting i
would be coughing i would be having
sinus issues so none of that
like i was like i could see myself
deteriorating from it
my skin not looking as good like none of
that really it but it was
the the dizziness is honestly quite
scary so like once you face
like if your addiction or your bad habit
takes you to a place where it's actually
really quite scary and you're concerned
for your own life
it's kind of easier to drop it it's
almost like a bottom like a you hit rock
bottom kind of thing but i don't even
know if it was related to smoking
the fact that you kept it up though is
is the part where you should be
i'm just so scared that it's related i
just never
i'm so scared of those dizzy spells
coming back that i just won't do it
that's how i quit six years ago too and
i swear
i felt the same thing as you for some
reason i felt so dizzy i had to like sit
down i thought i was gonna fall over
yeah and then like the smell of it the
taste of it suddenly just felt gross to
me
i i thought i was pregnant i was like
did i appreciate it i wasn't thank god
um and then after that it just stopped
and there have been times where i'm like
let me try it again and see if it and it
wouldn't work yeah but now it's just
like i have to be absolutely
furious to smoke a cigarette like that's
how you know like gina's angry
she's pissed off yeah and it doesn't
happen yeah i'm too scared
i'm like too scared to even touch it now
i think it's like if you had a drug and
then you
did a drug overdose then you would be
too scared to touch it yeah that's kind
of
a traumatic event also i i quit doing
coke i used to do coke when i was
younger
and i had to quit that i'm very glad you
gave up that um yeah so i've had a lot
of bad habits
you guys knew this i was a lot less
reliable when it came to call times and
stuff
oh great you have the growth so much
well the thing is like the weird thing
is like
i i didn't make it a habit or something
i just
did it you voted for a new identity yeah
you're someone that makes it on time now
did i do that i don't know
i just so if the whole thing is decide
what type of person you want to be
and prove it with small wins over and
over and over again and then you become
that person uh it does feel like a small
little victory whenever i show up before
one of you guys yeah
it's a nice feeling yeah that's awesome
i like today it was nice
i'm better than you also also i think um
something that i realized too was like
when we first started this
show uh back when geo started the show
yeah um i i was so
nervous to speak and i like the thought
of actually like
um kind of hosting an episode was like
impossible tonight
i was like it's only nikki or geo or
maybe tiff like even
if you don't like it because you only
like posting jk news because you have
the the yeah
they have the music on when i host this
show i'm like yeah
and then i remember the first few times
once we uh switched everything over to
big mood where the first few times where
i try to host an episode and it was like
the most awkward [ __ ] for me
if i felt like so out of place but i was
like i want to be able to
yeah run an episode too like i want to
be it didn't feel awkward for us
yeah it was weird for me it felt so
uncomfortable and i was like oh i hate
it i don't even want to see what people
are going to say
like it was the worst but then i just
kept doing it because i i think
it was like identity wise i wanted to be
an important part of the show too i
didn't want to just be the quiet meek
one yeah so
my identity needs were
like pushing me to do it yeah those
small wins
i was like oh [ __ ] i can't i am this
person i can handle
like pushing the episode along you know
and it's not
scary anymore right but when you got
nervous did your
armpits maybe sweat a little bit my
armpits smelled a lot
and you know what makes them smell
better
native have you guys ever sat on santa's
lap and wondered god
i wonder if he thinks i smell no no
because usually he smells pretty bad
really all of that as i had smelled so
good what yeah well you got lucky you
didn't have santa from the south
jesus christ with the holiday season
right around the corner we're all
getting into the spirit by indulging in
the sights
and sounds and scents of the season one
thing i made sure to do was update my
native collection with their
candy cane holiday scent deodorant that
smells like candy cane i [ __ ] love
that smell
do you yes i have like peppermint
flavored
i have a lot of peppermint flavored
things and that's kind of like candy
cane smell oh
so make sure you guys don't smell
terrible when you guys go to your family
gatherings this year
wear deodorant please i'm begging you to
please wear deodorant that's important
native deodorants don't just block odor
better they're made better
native has ingredients you've heard of
like coconut oil and shea butter it's
also vegan and never ever
ever tested on animals a native never
uses ingredients that shouldn't be in
deodorant like aluminum
parabens sulfate or talc their candy
cane gift set also makes for a great
gift option
and all native products are great
stocking stuffers for everyone on your
list because everyone can use deodorants
can you guys tell that i've dealt with a
lot of smelly people yeah a lot of
gamers are pretty stinky
let's be honest you haven't dealt with
stinky santas
that's true that's true native is risk
free to try
every product comes with free shipping
within the united states plus
free 30-day returns exchanges see why so
many people love native and check out
the over 14 thousand
five-star reviews shop natives holiday
collection today by going to
nativedio.com
big mood girls or use the promo code big
mood girls at checkout
and get 20 off your first order that's
nativedeo.com
big mood girls or use promo code big
mood girls at checkout for 20
off your first order yeah smell good for
the holidays
please and our second sponsor which is a
perfect sponsor for this episode is new
new uh will help you achieve your goals
it's based in psychology
it teaches you why you do the things you
do and empowers you with the tools to
break the bad habits and replace them
with better ones so like for me during
this pandemic not having a gym or a
trainer i've started to eat
so much junk i'm eating so much
chocolate candy
and even milk like i'm eating cereal and
milk and all this crap and i'm like why
am i
why do i keep doing this to myself every
time i go to the grocery store i'm like
stop buying it but then i buy it anyway
and so i think
you know this is going to help me to
scale back
on eating so much junk and i really want
to have more energy i think that's also
why i'm not working out because i'm
eating so much sugar so i don't have
energy it's like i need a reminder like
hey
on my phone stop [ __ ] eating the
sugar but this is why
maybe you're doing that um so it's based
on a cognitive behavioral approach
that's kind of like therapy like it
helps you get
down to the bottom of it it uses
personalized courses to help you reach
your specific goals
over 80 percent of numerous finish the
program and over 60 percent have stuck
with their goals for at least a year
that's huge because most people do not
stick with their goals yeah
they're in their systems yeah talking
about it right now so obviously
this will help you maybe stay in the
flow
of that new goal there's a science to
getting healthier it's called noom
sign up for your trial today at noom
that's n-o-o-m
dot com slash big mood what do you have
to lose
visit noom.com big mood to start your
trial today
that's n-o-o-m dot com slash big mood
yeah so you guys want to know the best
way to start a habit sure tell me
okay so he talks about these things
called implementation intentions
whereas you're more likely to do
something if your brain is planned for
it so
if you tell yourself i will do x
activity at y
time at z location so i will meditate
for 20 minutes
at 7 00 a.m in my office you're more
likely to follow through on that because
it's like you made an appointment with
yourself
your brain is expecting it what's the
what's the alternative
because if i'm gonna prepare if you're
just like i want to meditate more
instead of saying i want to meditate
more or like i want to read more books
remember one day and you'll like do
binge yeah but you don't
make it consistent so you tell yourself
instead
and oh and by the way if you leave out
one of these you're less likely to do it
too
so you leave out the location you leave
out the time you leave out the amount of
time or whatever so it's like a brain
hack
yeah exactly this is a very like
personality a kind of thing
and it doesn't really work out for me
because you want to know something weird
so my when i grew up my family was
[ __ ] mentally insane
yeah and my aunt used to force me she's
like i want you to write down every
single thing that you do
as a kid so like i used to have or else
i would get my ass beat right so it's
like
404 i dusted the tables 405. i did
so you have a negative association with
negative association with lists
and schedules you need therapy for that
you'll be happy yeah you definitely need
therapy for that but you'll be happy to
know that there's something else you can
do instead as an alternative
you can do habit stacking um where it's
like a
you associate your new habit with
something you already do every day so
if you brush your teeth every morning
you go i'm going to take my medicine
after brushing my teeth every day so
like i did this with birth control pills
or it was like i needed to take my pill
every time at the same time
so i would associate it with a different
habit that i always do
i do that with my skin care yeah exactly
if you can do that
you can do that you have like a thousand
[ __ ] steps skincare program
yeah you can do other shows anything you
wanna integrate into your life just add
it to your skincare
part tell yourself that it will make
your skin glow put rna cream on
until you do this you know what you need
that would actually help your skin too
is keep a water bottle by your [ __ ]
skincare
that water with water like oh yeah yeah
because you drink it
i bought myself one of those giant
bottles and i forced myself to drink it
this girl
like people yell at me on my stream well
also you know what helps your skin and
all you care about is vanilla yeah
i'm just kidding that's true like after
you take off your work clothes you'll
immediately change into your workout
clothes so it's like
one habit goes in dude i've been wearing
workout clothes
like there was this one no no no not to
sleep in but there was this one week
where every morning
i get out of my pjs and put workout
clothes and not once that i work out in
the whole week
oh my god but i was like hey
hey that's the effort in that yeah right
yeah at least you went through the first
step
yeah yeah you just gotta stack the next
step of like
stretching maybe so he talks about this
dopamine feedback loop where
every habit you've ever created has been
part of this
cycle this reward system and so um
the ways to what you should examine is
making a new habit obvious make it
attractive
make it easy and make it satisfying and
that's how you will incorporate a new
habit into your life and then conversely
if you want to break
a habit make it not obvious make it not
attractive
make it not easy and make it not
satisfying
so with making it obvious it's like how
supermarkets design their products
there's studies that show that people
are
more likely to buy based on not what the
product is but
where the product is yeah so they those
ad companies they
are the like you know brands will pay
for that middle shelf right because
people will most likely just do
the most obvious thing
it's they'll yeah right there well also
they put certain things at kids eye
level so that they'll grab this
yeah exactly so the trick is to design
your environment to make the cues
for the best choice more obvious to you
so put your book next to your bed to
read more
uh so much [ __ ] on my nightstand cause
i'm like i'm gonna do that i'm gonna do
that i'm gonna do that and just ignore
all of it
it's just stacked and now i can't find
anything maybe i just need one i just
need one no it's actually organized
like i've been wanting to put cuticle
oil on my eyes
i did the same thing my cuticles are a
wreck and that's i can never
keep my kids erect i'm like a wreck
my cuticles are a reaction
[Laughter]
so i had for me with this cute this very
same thing the cuticle oil
i needed to incorporate it in no matter
where i put it like if i was putting it
on by my skincare i just wouldn't do it
i finally found the perfect place okay
which is in front of my computer
so while i'm waiting for my videos to
upload i put it on my cuticles so
i have it stacked and i put it in a very
obvious
place like where i'm normally grabbing
things anyway hey it works because then
i
was i i mentioned that i stopped
journaling and my friend was like no
that's not good and he gifted me a
journal so i keep it next to my bed now
and i'm journaling and you're a person
that journals now yeah
i want to be that person too stack it on
that nightstand stare at it
yeah just starting to stand as a dead
bucket it's just like a
graveyard it's like you're on your own
stand you're like yeah that's what you
want me to do yeah yeah
dude that's literally my brain with all
the things i want to do
yeah like they're all just like in there
it's like oh i want to do that and i
want to do that and i want to do that
and i never get to
i have to trick myself like how jess
when you're talking about cleaning how
like one thing leads to the next thing
like you're mopping and then you see
something on the walls and then you
clean the walls i have to put it in my
path
of my work day so if i want something to
be done it can't be
just at the end of the night on the
nightstand it has to be like in the path
like
on my way to get the stuff out food out
of the kitchen
i have my running shoes like it's like
right there on the path
my water bottle is on the counter right
next to the coffee so before i make my
coffee
i fill that water bottle up and drink
the water um
that makes sense because like there's a
lot of time where i'm like fidgeting and
stuff on the computer and if i
have my cuticle oil there i think i will
pick it up yeah that would that ended up
being the place because i'm like i
fidget with other things yeah
so might as well put healthy things
there um i don't i didn't even realize i
was doing these little things
yeah right good job yeah that's kind of
like how i felt reading this book i was
like oh that's why that didn't work oh
that's why that did work
oh yeah yeah that's great um also
he this is relevant to all of us to
divide your house up so your cues don't
get
mixed you know how like our phones we do
it for everything we call people on it
we
browse social media we do work on it so
it's like very mixed it's like
your phone is not oh i've got to do work
now or oh i've got to be social now
so it sends confusing signals to our
brains so he was talking about how
working from home he used to work in the
living room but then it was hard to draw
the line between
what's work and what's personal because
it all bleeds into it so it led to him
over working
so then he finally upgraded to having an
office which tiff i just
got one yeah oh man it's such a it's
like all the work stays in there yeah
because i used to
work from my bed like i would literally
never leave my bed
and i'm always there and i'm like [ __ ] i
never i can never separate personal from
work or
anything like that yeah and if you have
a small place like you can't
afford to upgrade to like having an
office um he suggests having like just
different activity
areas so like work is only at this desk
right um browsing the internet is only
on this couch
you know like seven different areas for
that
uh and then obviously the converse to
breaking into uh
breaking bad habits is reducing exposure
to the queue that causes it so if you
can't get work done
move your phone to the other room if you
continually feel like you're not enough
psychologically stop following social
media accounts that trigger jealousy and
envy
stop reading youtube comments you know
you're tired of this [ __ ] boy wasting
your time
block him lock him on instagram don't
answer his phone calls
remove your exposure kill him no no no
no oh blah
blah blah you're on camera gina all
right
block it block him redacted
[Laughter]
so then make your new habit attractive
make it
sexy uh the journaling thing you were
talking about journaling
dude my trainer that was the only reason
why i showed up
that was the only [ __ ] reason why i
showed up ever like every two days
and then he had to work but now the
pandemic is
is i can't see him so um so they
discovered
that um the anticipation of a reward
not the fulfillment of it is what gets
us to take action
yeah the same part of the brain that's
activated by receiving a reward
is is activated during the anticipation
stage so like when your kid on christmas
they're like waiting to open your
presents is just as rewarding as
opening the anticipation of anything is
always better than the actual thing
yeah to be quite honest well except for
maybe an orgasm because
that's pretty cool and like waiting for
one is not pretty cool
i like the process yeah but yeah
well for me i was i was disagreeing
because i'm like i'd rather be on the
vacation than waiting for the vacation
or like i feel like but i feel like the
excitement
that's fun like the excitement planning
it though like
you know like it's in your head
nothing's really happened yet yeah you
can build it up but then like when
you're on vacation and you're like
standing in line and you're like [ __ ]
this is taking longer
no dude i love all that i'm weird
so he talks about temptation building so
um
like when you're trying to incorporate a
new habit like building that
anticipation
like he gives an example of abc
designing their program
um their programming they had this thing
called tgit thank god it's thursday
because people weren't really watching
tv on thursday
so they created this programming that
encouraged viewers to drink wine and
have some popcorn while you're watching
tgit so people started associating
8 p.m on thursdays with relaxation and
being entertained
and they saw viewership go up a bunch
comes in with marketing or like
um people have done things like i can't
watch netflix unless i'm on the
treadmill watching netflix
or if i have personally if i have to
edit a video
um i'll say like okay i have to edit for
two hours straight and then i can have
15 minutes of social media
so it's like i really want to check out
this new thing that i just saw
right but i can't do it until i work for
two hours or getting new gym yeah that's
hard because me i'm like a person
discipline is the biggest thing to
overcome i'm a person of indulgence
yeah so make something so with the
journal right have some like
really pretty pens like i can't buy
myself some new pen see there you go
it's like you can't use your pretty new
pens unless you're writing in your
journal it's true
i'm not a journal person i really really
tried that's okay
i i want it to be like it it helps like
when i'm going through something
extremely [ __ ] difficult for like a
day or so like i get it all out but like
i don't think i can be a regular dude
but i think
because i just remembered why i'm not
because when i tried when i was a
teenager
um i i found out my mom was reading my
journal
and i feel like i'm never safe like i'm
never private that's what happened to me
and i stopped for a long
time yeah so for that reason i'm like i
really want to because i feel like it
would help me i think
every time i'm like i'm about to i'm
like this isn't safe
yeah just make your handwriting
illegible
you gotta start he's gonna start writing
in pig latin or something so it's like
hard and exhausting to read it i think
it's also like when people think of
journaling they think like oh these long
elaborate yeah i just write random
[ __ ] that comes in my head
yeah weiner mine's just literally that
sounds fun maybe i could do that
like i find a quote that i like or like
a word i want to look up later or like i
just
doodle it doesn't have to be like
full-on journal that's so true
yeah because i like taking notes yeah
like for books and stuff
but not just like my thoughts but i
think that's why i have so much like
um rumination issues yeah because i
don't ever like
put it get rid of it like put it
you know like i just keep ruminating for
sometimes i write about my schedule in
there because that's
whatever's like taking all my brain
space i just need to dump it out on the
paper yeah
sometimes it's random [ __ ] words
sometimes i'm like just recapping
something i read in a book because i
just need to get it out of my head
yeah i think i'm so perfectionist though
that like if i
can't write in the journal and it like
looks good or if it's oh you can't think
about that
yeah yeah so like i'm like i i mean
everything is so
my hand doesn't know how to spell
anymore so i'm like
i do all kinds of spelling errors and
mine i'm like i don't know yeah that's
why i relate to the perfectionist thing
but that's why i started journaling
because the whole [ __ ] perfect thing for
me
is i i'm a perfectionist too when it
comes to that kind of stuff where
i want to look back at it and like go oh
how perfect
cute and pretty but i really needed to
break that habit and so that's why i
made myself
journal all the time and just get
whatever and like nothing's perfect
everything's a mess
but you're just getting it out it's just
the habit of getting it out and it it
really does make a difference
you know one thing you should try though
if that's really hard for you is um
morning pages there's a book called the
artist's way and i bought that book but
then i never went through it
oh still sitting in my house the first
activity she has you do
is um every day you write three pages
you just
make sure your hand does not stop moving
across the page it could be literally
anything
you could just write blah blah blah if
you want but your hand just keeps moving
and you will find that stuff just gets
dumped out that
doesn't need to be in there anymore and
then she has you throw away those pages
like you literally reminded me of the
second reason why i don't write down my
thoughts
which was i went to this like weird ass
retreat thing when i was 15 living in
mexico
and it was like a three-day retreat they
didn't let us sleep
we didn't eat it's like it was [ __ ]
cult induction yeah it was like
it was [ __ ] crazy and that entire
time they had us right on
on a blank sheet of paper for an entire
night and without sleeping and if you
fell asleep they'll yell at you and it
was it was [ __ ] crazy dude that's how
they
um brainwash people like that's some nk
mk ultra yeah
well the whole thing was like they were
trying to get us to write
our traumas and our all the bad [ __ ]
that happened in our lives and this was
in mexico so everyone was writing like
i'm
literally being traumatized right now
right this here yeah
super culti yeah and so i was the only
one that wrote in english
because that's my first like main
language and um
and so they actually i got in trouble
for writing in english
and um and then so like that was the
first night like the first day first
night was just
writing non-stop the whole night and
then the next day
they assign you to a person called the
ear la reha
and then you you're supposed to read
everything that you wrote to this person
oh no that's some scientology stuff
and then so i did that and then like i'm
[ __ ]
i'm 15 at this point and like i i was
like
right like i just have never had privacy
whenever i write yeah yeah
so like all this [ __ ] like talking about
journaling i'm like you know
it's we're gonna get you one of those
90s diaries with the key the plastic
or no it just has a code yeah no one can
find the keys it has like a luggage
[ __ ] car oh yeah i wanted that yeah
you need to develop something that
associates it with being safe
right yeah maybe the maybe the burning
it
like writing it and then burning it yeah
yeah well after we read it to this
person they had us throw it in a bonfire
so yay our
our problems how did you get signed up
to this yeah
it was wild what just it's a whole
another story jesus
christ i wasn't the only one i went with
some family members
yeah so we're at an hour right now but
the last two things we're making it easy
and making it satisfying you can kind of
infer
what that means but making easy is like
you know creating the right environment
for it and making it satisfying
the like habit tracker i like like um
keeping track of my habits when you
don't see progress on a day to day basis
it gets hard to keep up with the habits
but when i get to actually visually see
a box getting checked off
it's super satisfying to me it's like a
little baby reward
and then over time you get the bigger
reward
um but yeah there's a lot to this book i
highly recommend it it's
it's got it's filled with different
studies from sports
to business to uh relationships to every
little thing
i think it just covers a lot of the
topics that we cover here and
just how to make your life one percent
better each day
and it's the name of the book again it's
called atomic habits by james clear not
sponsored shout out to james clear
really wonderful but quick read too
like if you're not a reader yet yet
this read goes really fast i think i
read it in like two days because it was
just like
it's super easy to digest um and also
a good habit would be to like this video
and rate us on yeah
it gives you endorphins it makes your
skin glow
every tuesday
i heard that every time you like one of
our videos your wiener grows by point
one percent what if i don't compound
your boobies your vagina compound yeah
whatever my vagina will be tight
everybody loves doll hairs all right we
love you guys hope you enjoyed this
we'll see you next time bye